hello everyone and welcome to today's
tutorial on affiliate marketing I'm
thrilled to have you here so let's walk
on a journey into the dynamic realm of
affiliate marketing now just a quick
info for you if you want to upskill
yourself master digital marketing skills
and land your dream job or grow in your
career then you must explore simply
learn's cohort of various digital
marketing programs simply learn offers
various certifications and post-graduate
programs in collaboration with some of
the world's leading universities like
spj puru and meta through our courses
you will gain knowledge and work ready
expertise in skills like search engine
marketing strategies for paid campaigns
analytics Roi and evaluation and over a
dozen of others that's not all you'll
also get the opportunity to work on
multiple projects and learn from
industry experts working in top TI
product companies and academian from top
universities after completing these
these courses thousands of Learners have
transitioned into digital marketing role
as a fresher or moved on to a higher
paying job role and profile if you're
passionate about making your career in
this field then make sure to check out
the link in the pin comments and
description box to find a digital
marketing program that fits your
experience and areas of Interest today's
tutorial promises to be an Enlighten
experience as we delve into the
fundamental aspects of affiliate
marketing equipping you with the
knowledge and skills needed to navigate
this exciting landscape in this video we
will cover basics of affiliate marketing
how to find a niche joining an affiliate
marketing program and explore platforms
where you can effectively promote your
affiliate products so let's dive in
first thing first what is affiliate
marketing affiliate marketing is a
performance-based marketing strategy
where individuals or businesses known as
Affiliates earn a commission by
promoting others people's or Company
products when a sale is made through
Affiliates unique link they receive a
percentage of the revenue imagine it as
a partners ship with individuals or
businesses called Affiliates becomes a
brand Advocates and earn a commission
for every successful sale they
contribute to it's a win-win scenario
the affiliate earns a percentage of the
revenue and the company gains a new
customer now let's talk about finding
your affiliate Niche your Niche is
essentially the specialized Market or
area of interest you will be focusing on
whether it's health and wellness and
technology or lifestyle finding a niche
that aligns with your interest and
expertise is Paramount this target
approach not only enhances your
credibility but also ensures that your
promotional efforts resonate with your
audience research trending products and
industries and consider the audience you
want to Target this helps you narrow
down your options and find a niche that
resonates with you and your potential
customers now the next step is joining
an affiliate program once you have
pinpointed your Niche the next step is
to join an affiliate program there are
various affiliate networks and
individual companies programs to choose
from so now let's do a demo let's
navigate to Google and let's type so
first of all whatsoever affiliate
marketing whatsoever company you want to
do affiliate marketing for all you have
to do just type the name of that company
and then the affiliate program so let's
say I want to do affiliate marketing for
a company called Nike I'll type Nike
affiliate
program all right so as you can see what
is the Nike affiliate program so we'll
click on this and let's see
so here as you can see what is the Nike
affiliate program they have explained
after that apply Now button is there
FAQs if you have any questions regarding
FAQs then you can go through it like
what are the benefits of Nike's
affiliate program once you have accepted
into Nike's affiliate program you can
benefit from the following perks earn up
to 11% Commission on all valid sales
30-day cookie period now what is Cookie
period now what is tracking time time or
frequency in affiliate marketing
tracking time or frequency means keeping
an eye on how long people engage with
ads or click on links this helps
marketers understand which times are
most effective for their promotions by
studying these patterns they can improve
their strategies focusing on when people
are most active this way Affiliates can
make their campaigns work better
targeting the right times and getting
more values for their efforts it's like
figuring out the best moments to show ad
so that more people notice and respond
to them now what is Cookie duration so
in affiliate marketing a cookie is a
small piece of data stored on a user's
device after clicking an affiliate link
cookie duration specifies how long this
information remains on the user's device
example a product has a cookie duration
of 60 days if someone clicks your
affiliate link a cookie is stored on
their device if they make a purchase
within the next 60 days you receive a
commission all right then full range of
category specific affiliate banners etc
etc etc now there is requirements like
who can become a Nike affiliate partner
so so all of these companies have their
own requirements so we have partnered
and established websites including sport
sites fashion clothing shoe sites news
sites health and fitness sites true
content sites and bloggers Etc so if you
fall under the category of any of these
then you can do affiliate marketing for
Nike all right how will my customer
benefit from me joining Nike affiliate
program so these are all the benefits
that you will get all right now if you
want to do or join this program you can
click on apply now all right now you can
read all these key reasons to start
promoting Nike today and then you can do
if you have already have an account at
Ain then you can login and join program
otherwise you'll have to sign up and
join the program so let's click on sign
up and join so here we'll not be showing
how to do the complete process but you
can go through all of these and do the
thing so there they have written are you
an Instagram influencer great news we
have made a joining a even easier if you
are Instagram influencer then you can
click on this sign up here button
otherwise join a is there so let's click
on join aan and there you have to put
the company name tax residency first
name last name and the complete details
after filling all these details you will
be you can see promotional type
promotional space verification after
completing this you will be provided a
affiliate link so that you can use
whatsoever wh soever you want to use in
your blogging sites Etc so this is how
you can do affiliate marketing in Nike
once you have approved into the
affiliate program you can usually log in
to your affiliate dashboard there you
will find a section where you can search
for the products you want to promote
after selecting a product the system
will generate a unique affiliate link
for you this link contains it's a
special tracking code that identifies
you as the affiliate use the affiliate
link once you have your affiliate link
you can use it to promote the product
through various channels as your website
blog social media or email marketing
when someone clicks on your affiliate
link and makes a purchase the system
tracks the sales back to you and you can
earn a commission so all right now let's
do affiliate marketing for my protein
another V protein brand very famous it
is so we can type my
protein
affiliate
program all right so here's the link
became an affiliate you can click on
that all right as we can see here want
to become a my protein influencer the my
protein influencer programming is an
easy way to monetize your website the
benefits as we can see the benefits can
go as high as 8% Commission on all sales
that you are drive you the via the
website we'll also benefit with
exclusive affiliate promotions and the
cookie period is 30 days cookies so so
if you will make a purchase in the next
30 days you will get benefit out of it
you'll get a commission now uh we'll
support you along the way all right
apply now so as you can see we want to
partner with the best people in the
fitness space while introducing more
customer to our great brand we look
forward to working with you please
ensure you fulfill this condition found
here so again as I told every company
has their own conditions or requirements
so my protein has their own requirements
so we'll click on here so as you can see
influencer and Affiliated Partners so
they have mentioned the benefits 8%
commission 30-day cookie period in-house
affiliate team to respond to request Etc
so now the thing is approval if you have
a social media profile with over 10,000
followers and would like to work as an
influencer please email to to this email
account to assist you with a query
please include all the links of your
social media profiles and an explanation
as to why you think you would be a great
fit for team M protein we do have strict
approval process and we so they have
clearly mentioned we do have strict
approval process and we will make a
decision based on multiple factors most
importantly whether or not your profiles
are brand aligned with my protein so
these are the conditions they have put
on if you fulfill all the conditions and
then only they can go forward with your
program or your marketing affiliate
marketing and these are the FAQs terms
and condition then now there is no apply
button to directly apply for this
affiliate program you'll have to mail
yourself and what all things what all
influencer marketing you do and which
kind of influencers are you if you have
10,000 plus followers then only you can
mail to this person or this team and let
them know
and attach the links they have asked for
then only they can uh go forward with
your program so this was about how you
can become an affiliate marketer for my
protein now let's do another one click
Bank
affiliate
program all right as you can see
Affiliates all right so ClickBank is
over 10,000 Affiliates for by choose
ClickBank as their preferred Marketplace
and for a good reason we have paid 6.1
million in commissions on time for more
than 25 years so they have written in
this so start here we'll click on that I
think we have to login as well but let's
just do this first let's customize your
ClickBank experience please select the
primary reason you're signing in so I'm
new to all this and not sure I want to
promote ClickBank I I have a product I
want to sell on ClickBank I'm just
creating a new nickname and others so
let's select the first one I'm new to
all all of this then no problem you you
are at the right place and we're excited
to help you okay let's go what is the
biggest Factor motivating you to explore
affiliate marketing so they have given
four options again earn extra income
quit my day and be my own boss turn my
passion into career and others so let's
write earn extra income do you currently
have traffic or audience to promote yes
I have if you have you can select this
otherwise you can select no I do not
have a consistent traffic all right so
how do you plan on generating traffic so
let's just click on YouTube first all
right select all of the ClickBank tools
you would be interested in using let's
say email marketing tool okay how did
you hear about us so let's say YouTube
video last question what is the email
address would you like to use for this
new account so you have to type your
email address and then you can go for
forward with it so you can also log in
after logging in they'll be telling you
or guiding you through how to the
complete signin process and then you can
proceed with that so this is how you can
do affiliate marketing at ClickBank
first you'll have to sign in and then
you can proceed with further you can
also and make sure to read the
requirements and the commission you'll
get from each and every company or a
product now let's talk about about the
platforms to promote affiliate links so
the platforms where you can effectively
promote your affiliate products social
media platforms like Instagram Facebook
and Twitter are great for reaching a
broad audience additionally content
platforms such as YouTube and blogging
sites allow you to create valuable
content and drive traffic to your
affiliate links don't forget about
forums like Cura where you can engage
with potential customers and provide
helpful recommendations so now let's
navigate to Google and let's type
Q now we'll click on
this all right continue with
Google all right so here it is
CA so here you can also promote the
affiliate links because there's a
traffic over here as well so all you
have to do is to just select the
category which you want toe let just say
let's just say we are promoting a v
protein brand you are promoting a v
protein brand so we'll click on this and
we can also type here best W routine
Etc and you'll get the questions
similarly like what is the best W
protein brands in India what is the best
W protein brand for building muscles etc
etc so you can answer these questions by
clicking on this and by answering these
questions you can also attach a link and
make sure that the information you share
in Cur will be like proper information
and you have used that product
personally then only you can recommend
because then only you'll be your
audience will be attached with you
because it's a relationship that you
will build then only they'll trust you
so you can do that like that like
multiple questions are there you can
answer each and every questions and
attach the affiliate link of that
particular product this is also a way as
you can see if you click on questions
and these are the questions some people
have used as well I think and they have
mentioned
so this is a great way for promoting or
doing the affiliate marketing you can do
like this as well a lot of people do
like this another way is through YouTube
whether you're building a website
YouTube channel or any other platform
it's crucial to acknowledge that you
must reveal the use of affiliate links
the Federal Trade Commission that is FTC
mandates transparency when earning
income through endorsements emphasizing
the importance of openly disclosing such
affiliations so as I said YouTube is a
great way of promoting or doing
affiliate marketing so let's take the
same example again best way protein
we'll be taking this example only so as
you can see there are multiple
influencers out there and let's just
select this video so you can promote or
like do affiliate marketing in videos in
your own videos because a lot of traffic
after Google comes to YouTube and the
traffic you can navigate that
traffic
yeah so you can navigate that traffic to
your affiliate link so as we can see
this guy has attached an affiliate link
and also get up to 40% on this protein
powder so you can click on this and he
can get a commission out of it
and make sure that the product you are
promoting or doing the affiliate
marketing is the right product and then
only you can build a relationship with
your audiences so as as you can see this
guy has done that so you can do that and
this guy has like 340,000 views and
let's say if he's getting 2,000 or 3,000
clicks on this protein by suggesting
them so he'll get the commission a lot
of commission from that so this is a
nice way of promoting or doing the
affiliate marketing and this is how this
is a great way in fact this is the best
way I would say to do the affiliate
marketing because it is quite easy so
he's basically navigating that views or
that traffic to the affiliate link so
this is the another best way to promote
your or do the affiliate marketing
thanks for turning into our affiliate
marketing tutorial I hope you found
these insights valuable for kickstarting
your journey in the affiliate space
remember authenticity is the key to
building trust with your audience if you
have any questions or want to share your
experiences drop them in the comment
section below don't forget to like And
subscribe staying at ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here